crece la preocupación por la situación
de los Derechos Humanos en Qatar días
antes de la celebración de la copa del
mundo en especial el trato hacia la
comunidad lgbt y comas las
demostraciones de afecto homosexuales
están criminalizadas por el código penal
del país del Golfo árabe con hasta siete
años de prisión
Nancy pisar ministra del interior de
Alemania se pronunció hoy al respecto
nieva Para mí es importante conversar
con Qatar para ver si podemos hacer algo
por la seguridad de los fanáticos
alemanes durante la Copa del Mundo
proteger a las personas que aman a otras
personas de su mismo sexo y quieren
demostrarlo
estas declaraciones se dan luego de una
controversial entrevista de la
televisión pública alemana al embajador
catarí de la copa del mundo jalit salman
en la que escribió el homosexualidad
como un daño en la mente
por supuesto tales declaraciones son
terribles y esa es también la razón por
la que estamos trabajando para mejorar
las cosas en Qatar la garantía de
seguridad era muy importante para mí y
me la dio el Primer Ministro y el
ministro del interior el evento
deportivo que comenzará el 20 de
noviembre recibirá poco más de un millón
de turistas una cantidad que representa
casi la mitad de la población total
rescatar un reto logístico y cultural
para un país que aplica la ley islámica
en su expresión más radical el sunismo
bajavita